[Music]
it's time for et social study your quick
look at what the stars are posting
online Fantasia
forced to cancel her Memphis gig after
suffering second-degree burns on her
arms Sunday the singer's husband shared
a picture on her Instagram from the
hospital writing she steady asking the
doc can I perform tonight but we must be
wise and realized this isn't a race but
rather a marathon Fantasia's rep tells
ET she's resting comfortably and will
continue the tour on Wednesday SNL star
Pete Davidson is also taking time to get
healthy the 23 year old shared an update
on Instagram writing in part quote I
quit drugs and him happy and sober for
the first time in eight years meanwhile
Paris Jackson is set to make her small
screen debut on the Fox drama star
Michael Jackson's only daughter tease
the appearance with this
behind-the-scenes look this role is
really opposite to me and for it being
like my first real life on-camera acting
I think it's a good way for me to show
my acting capabilities good Neil Patrick
Harris and husband David Burtka twins be
any cuter Harper and Gideon paid a visit
to a New York Art Fair and hilarious
thanks to W Magazine here's Adam driver
Andrew Garfield
Lucas hedges and Alden Ehrenreich
reciting an iconic scene from clueless
I said RSVP because it's a sit-down
dinner but people came that like did not
RSVP so I was like totally buggin I was
like totally buggin totally buggin
[Music]